(thunder clap)
(audience applause)
- [Alan] So now I don't have
to get struck by lightning,
Fran's shown you what happens.
So I'm gonna follow on from that.
All right, 'cause I get
asked similar questions,
I get asked like "Dear Evil
Tester", emails come into me,
our Agile project is screwed up
and messed up, what can I do?
All right, 'cause people want to fix it,
people want to take
responsibility for that.
Where screwed up means some of the things
that Fran just talked about.
Where we've got no time
for testing by the testers.
We've got no time for
automating by the testers.
We've got no acceptance criteria
that the testers can use.
We've got no story details that we
as testers can understand,
we're not invited to meetings,
and so the tester's not being included,
we're not getting stuff we want.
And the fundamental problem is
that you're not actually Agile,
you're not actually
doing an Agile project.
You've called it Agile,
you've labelled it Agile,
you've got some ritual
that you call Agile,
you do stand-ups, you do retrospectives
but you don't learn from them.
The feedback doesn't come in
as input and you process it.
So what we have to do
then is we still have to
fight the good fight and
explain what Agile is
and try and do the Agile thing.
But we still have to work
with the actual reality
on the ground so there are
steps that people can take.
The first thing we have to do is
we have to get our own house in order.
Make sure that we know how to test things,
make sure that we are avoiding waste in
the testing that we do.
So that we're not writing big test plans,
we're not writing huge
amounts of stuff in advance,
we're keeping everything lean
so that we can respond effectively.
We need to make sure that we do own
the things that are ours to own.
So exploratory testing, that
we make sure that we do that.
That we do that properly,
we capture all the results
and we plan it in advance.
One of the things you
can do is you can use
the Agile words against
the fake Agile process.
So Agile has words like done, not done,
so when you're planning out your testing,
your exploratory testing,
and build charters,
whatever lightweight plan you want to do,
you say not done, then
you listen to things
that you want to do.
Then when you start doing them
you gather evidence you say done,
then you put them into a done list.
So then at the end when people try and go,
"can we close this story now? can we mark
the story as done?", in
their face there's feedback,
that it is not yet done,
'cause there's a bunch of stuff not done
and you're making it visible.
You're helping people understand and share
the pain that you've got.
The other thing we have
to do, and this is,
why we get in a mess because
in Agile you are supposed
to do the work of other people as well,
you are supposed to absorb things.
But that's what we have to not do,
you have to focus on the work that we do,
and not absorb the poor
output from other things.
So testers do not stay
late testing because
the story was delivered at
four o'clock in the afternoon,
while everyone else goes home.
If we absorb things, then we
help this bad process continue
and in a normal Agile
process you would want
to help out, you want to make it work,
but you're not in an Agile process.
We have to work with the reality,
and that means making
people share the pain,
making this stuff visible.
We have to give them a
reason to want to change,
because the system has to change itself.
We can only act on small things.
Thank you very much.
(audience applause)